hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
preview Yellow Jacket season 2 episode
8. The penultimate episode is here and
we don't have any promo photos as of yet
but we do have a teaser trailer to break
down episode 7 did a lot of work to get
us ready for the final two episodes and
made a promise that big things are gonna
happen before we get there so this is
what you've all been doing chasing
blackmailers and murdering lovers that's
a little reductive
the title of episode 8 is it chooses and
the episode description reads
it's only going to get worse from here
despite the whole winners never gonna
end thing the 1996 New Jersey State
girls soccer Champions decide to start
their spring training early with an
impromptu cardio session Cali encounters
an old flame van proves goalies Never
Say Die most of the adults intentionally
commune in the sharing Shack and Lottie
baby I hear the blues are calling for
toss salad and scrambled eggs for that
first line given that there was a
literal burial on the horizon going into
episode seven I found myself wondering
how else that title would apply to what
happens ever since the official season 2
trailer came out people were guessing
that the shot of the crime scene that we
saw in that would turn out to be the
police discovering Adam's torso so I
thought that there might be a connection
there but it turned out to be that but
also a lot more than that one when they
were all together Nat asked the other
adults what they remember about their
time in the wilderness and Ty responded
that some of those memories have just
been stuffed somewhere deep down the
idea of burying your memory seemed to
line up with things getting worse and a
darker turn now that the promise of a
new baby isn't there to hold the group
together and boy did we see hints of
that when Shauna beat the crap out of
Lottie at the end of the episode I'll
come back around to the impromptu cardio
session and Cali encountering her old
flame the last line is interesting it's
a reference to Frasier's theme song when
I looked that up they wanted to show
what Frasier does for a living without
referencing it directly tossed salads
and scrambled eggs are foods that are
mixed up just like frasers mixed up
collars and you get the idea in case you
don't know Frazier is a psychiatrist by
trade and this connects nicely with
Lottie acting as her own there
therapists throughout this season there
was something off there we could see
that coming it was something that we
kind of figured out before she did which
made it wild to watch it play out from
what we saw she thought she was seeking
out help because she was starting to
have visions again she wasn't exactly
getting good advice but this reveal
shows that she was a lot farther gone
than she thought and now she's had that
realization and since it ends with the
therapist dressed as the antler Queen it
seems like things will take a turn in
the present as well the trailer opens
with the adults all together in lottie's
sharing room it sounds like they're
filling her and being in on what
happened last season which as we were
reminded in the last episode was only a
week ago in this timeline Shauna thinks
it's a little reductive to describe what
they were doing as chasing blackmailers
and murdering lovers but considering
Jeff's call at the end of episode 7 and
how that puts Shauna Ty Nat and Misty
all on the hook for what happened to him
it does seem like those are the most
important details what's not said here
and what likely won't come out is all of
the additional deception and
complications that go with that how Jeff
was the blackmailer how Ty had hired
Jessica to figure out if any of them
would go public about what really
happened in the wilderness and that
Misty killed her as far as coming clean
I'm not sure if Misty will make it known
that she met Walter because of his
interest in Adam's case but he does seem
to be in a unique position to either
help them or make things worse after her
trip inside the sensory deprivation tank
she's ready to open herself up to him
but still doesn't know what the last
messages he sent her say or how he'll
react to the news that Adam's torso has
been recovered because this is yellow
jackets and because they appear to be so
right for each other it's hard not to
think that it'll all go wrong in a hurry
I had been thinking about those messages
and wondered if they might be about
Lottie because I do think he would go
look into her after Misty sent him away
from the compound we were reminded in
episode 7 that Lottie was in Switzerland
over a decade ago but that implies he
was there for a long time after they
were rescued I'm not sure how any of
that fits into the end of this season
but I'd like to learn more about what
Lottie did before she was leading this
intentional community in the wilderness
we hear Ty say we need to find a way to
stay alive and it can't be her then we
see her watch Mari and Misty placing the
skull on a stool and that unsurprisingly
after the beating that she took Lottie
is out of commission the way Ty says it
can't be her leads me to believe that
Lottie will be that way for some time
that she's not there to take on any kind
of leadership role and I like this idea
we're getting to the end of the season
and expecting something major to happen
in both timelines to set up what happens
next at this point I think having people
follow Lottie into some ritualistic
Shenanigans is less interesting than
seeing them doing it themselves does it
make sense for Tai to be the one to push
for it I guess that depends I think
Shauna will resist because she sort of
has to I mean she'll likely be
remorseful for what she did to Lottie
but I don't think that's a direct path
to becoming a True Believer and I think
Nat will also still be against this idea
at least to a point going into burial I
was wondering how the baby's death would
be interpreted by everyone who spilled
blood hoping the Wilderness would
intervene and save him Melissa and Jen
brought up the idea of the Wilderness
taking him and possibly giving them
something in return this is something
that the show has put some effort into
making us think about throughout the
series most recently with the drop of
blood on the baby blanket followed by
birds falling from the sky and hobbies
return after Lottie slashed her Palm
Lottie matter of factly declares that
the Wilderness did intervene by Saving
Shauna and given the situation you can
see how she'd adopt this point of view
and why that explanation would be
appealing in that it would mean things
aren't completely out of control she
also emphasizes that it doesn't trade or
haggle so it'll be interesting to see
how the other people interpret that I
zoomed in and still couldn't really make
out what the offerings are it looks like
the knife is there in a hair comb but
since the candle is in the middle
there's a shadow that makes it hard to
see what else is there Lottie does look
like she's in bad shape there's a shot
of Misty taking care of her and one
where it looks like she's having a dream
they were already starving and things
were desperate but her being in this
condition could intensify things and
make them feel like they have to act
fast Lottie being close to death and
dreaming could deliver some interesting
Visions obviously there is something
going on with Jackie's death dream and
the near-death dreams that have been
spread throughout this season I'm
expecting the hunter AKA cabin daddy who
welcomed Jackie to make another
appearance before this season ends and
there are pretty credible rumors that
we'll learn more about his story in a
flashback when that first came up I
wondered if Hobby's friend might be
connected to that since his story is
supposed to be like The Shining and in
the one behind the scenes photo that's
out there he was holding his daughter
this shot is a Melanie lynskey's husband
Jason Ritter who was announced to be in
this season he's not the same person
that played the character in season one
but I mean he's wearing that same jacket
the only warm jacket they found in the
cabin that just about everyone wears at
one time or another there's a voiceover
of Cali saying that her mom is like
seriously effed up and then we see the
cops show up at their house it looks
like they do you some tricky editing
here because you see Shauna standing
there but in other trailers it showed
that Jeff opens the door with Cali
standing right there behind him and then
their family portrait gets splashed with
blood based on everything else that's
happened and has shown up in trailers
this seems more likely to be a vision
than real but I mean something crazy is
bound to happen in these last couple of
episodes so I guess we'll have to wait
and see either way this is now a murder
investigation and it's at their doorstep
after that adult Lottie says we don't
get to decide it chooses which lines up
with where she's at and how she
understands the power of the Wilderness
there is a tray there with the
ceremonial drink for each of them I
don't have a great idea what's happening
there but at the very least it indicates
that they're in agreement to work
together this idea of not getting to
decide goes both ways it helps them move
forward it chooses something then they
move forward and do something they have
to do but also sort of absolves them
from responsibility when they're making
hard decisions I imagine this is
something that will come up throughout
the rest of the series what's more
interesting is that this is followed by
Van shuffling the deck of cards so that
someone has to pick one we've been
expecting that these would come into
play the popular theories are that this
is how they'll pick who the antler Queen
is if that's a rotating position with
Lottie at a commission they might be
picking who will lead a ritual or the
other theory is that this is how they'll
choose their victims when they get to
where they are in the pit Girl scene it
still feels a little early for them to
be hunting each other at least like this
if hobby were to freak out could I see
them hunting him down possibly it would
take something crazy but I guess they
could turn on someone this doesn't look
like that kind of situation though if
they're picking the cards that means
that they would have to have have a
consensus that this was a necessary
thing to do to survive sauna just lost
the baby and lottie's near death so
they're plenty traumatized but the way
this is put together also feels like
it's trying to misdirect us the thing
you see after the cards is Mari with a
scared look on her face and then she
looks terrified as she backpedals across
the room in that shot it looks like
everyone else is just lounging around
rather than waiting to find out who
their first victim is going to be the
sequence with Mari has been around since
the first trailer and I have no idea
what is scaring her we still haven't
gotten a payoff for her hearing the
dripping sound that seems like something
they have to tie up so it's possible
that she's just freaking out also I
think you're supposed to connect this
with the scene of them running with the
weapons and think they're hunting one of
their own a la pic girl and Mari is
clearly with them in those shots so even
if they are hunting a person all of
these things aren't connected that said
the look on Van's face wash she's
shuffling the deck and the way that
everyone who's standing around her looks
this all looks very important and we'll
set the stage at the very least for more
Sinister things involving the cards as
time goes on the scenes that look like
they're charging into battle are the
same way they've been around since the
first trailer and it's very hard to say
what's happening I was happy that we got
to a place where the crystal isn't real
theories died out but then you have to
ask where did her body go these two
things could be related I think the
implication is that something or someone
moved the body I think Misty looked in
the right place I don't know what
purpose it would serve for her body to
still be there undiscovered so that
narrows things down to an animal taking
her body to feed on it or other people
coming across it people we haven't met
yet moving the body Javi survived for a
long time and we still haven't found out
how all we know is that he told Ben that
his friend told him not to come back I'm
not a big fan of the other tie being
that friend I think it works in the
sense that there is a possible rational
explanation that that's what happened
but in my mind I just think it seems a
lot more likely that this hints that
there's someone else out there or
possibly some sort of entity that he
came across there's also that weird
detail of the girls asking Javi where he
got the Queen card in passing that was
so subtle it almost has to be important
you could see them chasing after an
animal but it would almost have to be a
situation where they thought it was a
gift from the Wilderness and then that
influences them to do crazy things later
at this point I just hope whatever
they're doing here is exciting and I'm
happy that we're finally going to find
out what it is the only other shots I
didn't mention are quick ones there's
one of teen Thai covering her face
inside the cabin one of Travis grabbing
something from Aquila which is probably
nugget related and one of Van grabbing
her weapon as they run out of the cabin
that makes the chase scene seem like
it's something that is developing in
real time not something that they
planned out it looks like they're
reacting to something that's happening
right then so let's just hope it's not
something like a wolf standing in the
front yard carrying shawna's baby which
wasn't buried that well at all when I
was watching her do that I did wonder if
it would go missing like Crystal did it
seems like it was in a place that she
would notice and that could certainly
cause her to continue freaking out and
she does still look pretty unhinged in
the one shot we see of her inside the
cabin so that's about it I'm curious to
see what happens with Ben now that he
came back from the edge I feel like it
could go either way I don't think he
would kill himself anymore but could
still see him dying in a totally
different way like where you think he's
safe and boom something happens or he
could do a big turn around which seems
more likely I thought it was notable
that Misty sort of cycled through all
these different threats to try to get
him to come back down off the ledge
nothing turned him around he even seemed
like he won wanted her to tell the world
he was gay like he was making peace with
that in the life that he wanted to live
but it seemed like what actually turned
him around was that he didn't want to
put them through that that he does care
for the team and if he was suicidal and
he didn't really care about himself it
would be natural for him to turn the
corner and try to find a reason to
survive I don't think Ben survives or at
least I don't think he goes back to
civilization I'm not sure how it will
play out but I think if he does survive
there's a real chance that when they get
rescued he'll stay behind Vance cancer
is another thing it doesn't look like
anything in the trailer is directly
related to that but with Lottie coming
unglued you have to wonder what she
might suggest they do if she finds out
about it she's already cut her palm and
made an offering and asked for that to
be all that was necessary but it seems
like the answer that she's getting might
be that it wasn't enough there are a lot
of loose ends in dangling threads for
them to pull on in these last two
episodes it should be exciting and
hopefully a lot of fun let me know what
you think is going to happen in the
comments please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
foreign